and I never thought I'd have a better
show than the office really really nine
Seasons 200 episodes everyone got along
made a big impact was funny as hell
it's great character great money like
fun fun people everywhere oh yeah I saw
Kevin scoping chicks at a club once did
you and it was like the best time ever
so cool yeah
um but didn't you almost have a show
right before the office that didn't go
through yes that's good good memory yeah
I was supposed to be on this um
Janine Garofalo uh TV show
and we did it and on the way to the
table read for it I ran into this TV
executive and he's like oh I'm so
excited we're going to do the American
version of The Office
and I had seen the English version I
loved it and I was like
ins I was outside I was like oh that's
great inside I was like [__] I want to
be on that
like okay you got to go to the table
read for this Janine and Janine's lovely
it's not about her but the pilot was
very good
we read the pilot Bob Odenkirk was in it
me and Bob Odenkirk nice man
um
and uh Mark Maron oh yeah yeah
and it went so the read through went so
bad they pulled the plug on the spot by
the time I got home they were like
they're not shooting they closed the
donuts up even huh and I was like inside
I was like I get to audition for the
office sure enough month later
auditioned for the office and got and
got Dwight a few months after that so
had I gotten so you never know kitties
yeah sometimes a rejection and a
disappointment is a good thing and it
just is a a path forward where other
doors can open oh yeah what they say it
sucks to lose a limb until you're in a
um one-legged contest
are there a lot on one-legged contests
I'm not sure can you Google that
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one